-Welcome back.
-It's great to be here.
-I'm always very happy
that you're about to come.
And we were texting.
And we'll text about
what we're gonna talk abou
when you come and -- and the
something happened at a rally.
Donald Trump
name-checked you at a rally.
-Yes.
And it wasn't nice.
-No.
-It wasn't nice.
-It wasn't nice at all.
Let's take a look, and then --
and just tell me what happen
in your brain
when the President says
this about you at a rally.
-Okay.
-Jake Tapper today,
he put out --
No, I know you don't like him.
Who likes him?
Who the hell --
I think his wife likes him
actually.
I really believe she does.
[ Laughter ]
-So, there's a couple
crazy things there.
He wasn't actually bringin
you up to disparage you.
Because he then was gonna
talk about reporting
that you had done that actuall
reflected well on him.
-Yeah, well -- yeah.
Or, less horribly.
-Less horribly. Yeah.
-I had some reporting
that suggested that a --
somebody who briefed
the House Intelligence Committee
maybe overstated the case
in terms of whether or not
the Russians preferred him
or just, you know, thought the
could deal with him, you know,
thought he was
a transactional dealmaker.
And some of the reporting
was like,
"Oh, no, the intelligence
community thinks that, you know,
they prefer him again."
And so it was actually
kind of helpful to him.
But see, what's so symboli
of how he gets in his own way --
he's so driven by vengeance...
-Yeah.
-...that even when he's gonn
cite my reporting,
he starts off
by telling everybody
that I'm completely unlikable.
[ Laughter ]
"This guy's horrible.
Don't listen to a word
he has to say."
"He said something good for me."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I --
you know, what I note is,
when you watch the clip,
one of the things that happens
is his -- the people at hi
rallies, you know, it is -
they like having villains.
-Oh, yeah.
-And so when he mentions
Jake Tapper, they start to boo
-Yeah. There was a stirrin
in the crowd.
-There was a stirring.
And so then he has to
revert back to what he's don
in the past.
-Right.
-Like, "Yeah, bad guy.
Bad guy Jake.
Anyway..." like he said...
-Although
he backed off a little.
He backed off --
"Who likes him?"
Who the hell likes him?
Well, his wife likes him."
-That I thought was nice.
[ Laughter ]
I thought that was really nice
There are some people
where he doesn't even
bring up their spouses.
-Yeah.
-How did your wife
react to that?
-Well, you -- you know my wife
-Jenn, wonderful.
-Do you think she likes me
-I do!
[ Laughter ]
I mean,
we've been out a few times
Like at least one of them,
she seemed into you.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
I'm told that she likes me
-But I need a second source.
-Yeah.
-So just a journalistic --
-But you couldn't report -
Does she -- Did she call you
after it happened?
-You know, it's so funny.
This is where we are now.
5 years ago, 10 years ago,
if something like this
had happened,
a president of the United States
insulted me
and brought my wife into it,
then, like,
I would've immediately
gotten a phone call
from my wife.
"Can you believe it?"
She hadn't even heard.
-Yeah.
-I'm like -- I texted her.
And I'm like, "You know, the
President just insulted me."
She's like,
"Yeah, okay, whatever."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "No, and he
brought you into it."
And she's like, "What?"
And I sent her the clip.
And she's like,
"Oh, that's so funny.
I haven't --
I hadn't heard that."
-Yeah.
-It's all just --
It's like, you know,
living in some crappy apartmen
right out of college,
and, like, the furnace
is constantly making noise
And by the, you know --
you don't even hear it
by the first week.
-Yeah.
-It's just, like --
She's like, "Oh, the President's
insulting you
and questioning your marriag
in front of an entire world?
And, like, "Oh, really? Okay."
-Yeah.
And then your parents come
and visit your dorm room,
and they're like,
"That's banging."
And you're like, "Is it?"
-"Can't hear it."
[ Laughter ]
"Can't hear it."
-"I had no idea."
-"It's just noise."
-You know, there is --
the very -- I think there --
Whether or not Russian
interference is gonna be
pro one candidate or the other
it does seem like
just causing chaos,
causing mayhem...
-They're succeeding.
-...causing doubt...
-They're succeeding, yeah.
-And there's no reason to thin
just because they
so effectively use technology,
and technology
advances every year,
that it won't be more effectiv
four years on from 2016.
How do you go about reportin
on the elections
when you know there's this
undercurrent happening?
We don't really, truly kno
many of the details.
-Yeah, no.
I mean, first of all, I think,
that 2016 was horrible,
but education for a lot of us.
You know, the first time tha
the DNC e-mails were hacke
and then released
through WikiLeaks,
the Clinton campaign came ou
and said, you know,
"We think it's the Russians.
But nobody
in the Obama administratio
was saying that publicly.
So it was --
There was an entire world
that didn't know
that the Russians
did this sort of thing.
Now we know.
We have more education.
We have more information.
And I think one of the things is
you have to be aware that a lo
of the stuff on social media
is just not real or it's lies.
And it's just something that
we all have to keep in mind,
whether it's your grandparents
reading things that
they see on Facebook or --
-Yeah.
-Not yours specifically.
-No, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Or, you know --
Or people on Twitter
who seem like real people,
and then it turns out
they're not
actually real people.
And they say that the Russians
this year are going to get
even more sophisticated becaus
they're gonna do stuff
from inside the United States,
so it's not even as detectable
as doing it from outside.
-You know, I think one of
the reasons it is so effective
is that we,
not just as Americans
but more as human beings, yo
want to believe things you rea
that serve your own messaging.
And so you don't have to b
that effective, it strikes me,
to trick someone
as long as you're saying
what they want to hear.
-Well, people always want
to believe the narrative
that they've bought into.
And, in fact, when I was
reporting the thing
that helped President Trump,
theoretically, on Friday,
it was really astounding
to see how many people
who wanted to believe the worst,
that the intelligence communit
had briefed
that the Russians
had a preference, which is true,
and that is was true,
it was definitely accurate
as opposed to some
national-security official
saying, "Hey, this briefer
got ahead of her skis."
It was really amazing to see
how many people just completel
started attacking
the national-security columnists
and commentators, or whatever.
Because people want to believe
what they want to believe.
There's also just
the impetus that people --
people are generally incline
to trust people.
-Yeah.
-You're generally inclined
to believe that the person
in front of you is not lying
And, you know,
even if we are being hit
with a barrage of lies
day in, day out.